[Musique]
bonjour heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau 7,8 les invités ont pas ce
titre parole à françois billot de
lochner il est candidat dans la première
circonscription des yvelines président
de la fondation de service politique et
versailles est depuis de nombreuses
années il représente la droite
conservatrice et puis nous recevons
jérôme warembourg réalisateur de la
websérie les chroniques aéro une
production réalisée par un yvelinois ces
vidéos remporté un franc succès sur
internet et on débute ce 7,8 les invités
avec la course aux législatives et nous
recevons ce soir françois bio de l'eau
claire et les candidats dans la première
circonscription des yvelines
il souhaite imposer une droite
conservatrice dans le département je ne
me trompe pas exactement alors c'est
votre première élection schéma premières
élections pourquoi avoir décidé de vous
présenter ça n'allait pas là écoutez je
gravite dans la vie politique depuis à
peu près 20 ans réfectionner donc j'ai
je connais bien la vie politique je
connais bien les acteurs de la vie
politique et j'ai décidé de me présenter
parce que je crois qu'on vit une époque
tout à fait extraordinaire où les
électeurs n'ont plus vraiment de choix
c'est un plus de repères ils n'ont plus
de repères et notamment les électeurs de
droite alors je ne parle pas des
électeurs de gauche parce qu'ils ont
leur propre façon de faire les choses
moi étant plutôt un homme de droite je
vais parler plutôt des électeurs de
droite
en fait aujourd'hui un électeur de
droite sur ma circonscription
si je ne me présenterai pas aurez le
choix globalement entre un front
national qui aujourd'hui est
complètement ostracisés et un peu hors
course il faut bien le dire
et des républicains dont personne ne
sait qui ils sont parce que quand on
vote républicain aujourd'hui je voudrais
quand même qu'on m'explique pour qui et
pourquoi on vote mais pourtant dans
votre circonscription c'est l'adjoint du
maire de versailles
voilà mon seul javier bellamy ont connu
ben oui mais françois lamy quéveau de
mort un garçon fort respectable a été
investi par un party les républicains
qui ne sait plus où il habite
les républicains ne s'appelaient il
habite selon vous c'est pas l'homme
c'est les idées je les ai dit j'ai tant
que vous pose concrètement les y dépose
année d'un problème est franche et
bellamy forcément ayant l'investiture
d'un parti comme les républicains
rentrer dans la mécanique des
républicains et je connais suffisamment
les républicains pour savoir que quand
on rentre dans la mécanique on est
absorbé par la mécanique donc la droite
conservatrice traditionnel libéral n'est
pas représenté aujourd'hui alors
parlons-en très rapidement vous devenez
député de la première circonscription
qu'est ce que vous mettez en place
qu'est ce qui ne va pas aujourd'hui
alors ce qui ne va pas assez
la liste est apprécié à faire un petit
oui alors je voulais juste que je peux
faire c'est vous donner quelques idées
force de ce que j'essayerai de faire si
je suis député en me battant vraiment
pour ça en prenant sur chaque secteur
1.1 pour ne pas multiplier choses sur le
plan politique
moi je souhaite que la france retrouve
un peu de souveraineté je pense que la
france a abandonné sa souveraineté à
l'europe
et je pense qu'il faut retrouver de la
souveraineté parce que la france doit
être dirigé par des français normalement
classiquement ça veut pas dire que je
suis contre l'europe
loin de là mais je suis plutôt pour une
europe des nations l'europe
technocratique ce n'est pas vraiment mon
affaire donc c'était ce que j'avais plus
lire en soit vous voulez vraiment quand
vous avez ce poste de député être contre
la politique pourrait faire emmanuel
macron très clairement
ah ben c'est emmanuel macron est très
très heureux pays stable avant donc là
on sera clairement nos mesures et sur un
autre point politique d'ailleurs je suis
un fanatique du référendum d'initiative
populaire
donc le référé d'initiative populaire ça
consiste à ce que 900 mille personnes
quand elles décident de faire un
référendum sur un sujet non justement
voilà ça pour moi c'est fondamental pour
bousculer le système et pour faire en
sorte que la classe politique ne
continue plus ce jeu de domination et
d'écrasement finalement de la volonté
démocratique
ça c'est pour la partie politique alors
on pourrait citer d'autres points
allez-y je vous en prie une ombre
méninges entend bien ce que vous dites
mais moi je me pose une question vous
êtes contre les idées des républicains
contre beaucoup d'idées des divers
droite à tous et au deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle vous avez plus
dit qu'il fallait voter marine le pen
plus tôt est ce que vous faites pas
partie de ces gens qui seraient plus
pour une droite rassemblés de toutes les
droites
c'est exactement ça c'est pas bon ménage
à travailler et vous avez très bien
travaillé je vous en félicite
mais sauf que la boule est divisée alors
oui et non alors ce que vous appelez il
faut ce qu'il faut bien définir le thème
le terme de droite rassembler la droite
rassemblée c'est une droite rassemblée
sur des valeurs extrêmement simple et
précise donc ce n'est pas une droite
pour tous c'est ce que je reproche aux
républicains aujourd'hui finalement
c'est d'être une droit de fourre tout où
on trouve touché l'est républicain que
cette droite forte qui dont on parle
dans beaucoup de livres qui est qu on
reprendrait de l'extrême droite jusqu'à
le
d où le modèle elle a jamais
véritablement fonctionné mais vous ça
serait plutôt vers ce abeba qui est
exactement ça une droite conservatrice
il y aurait à droite dans une
recomposition de la droite tel que je
l'imaginé il y aurait un front national
c'est la droite nationale très précis
sur un certain nombre de choses
l'est républicain devenu un espèce de
partis centristes qui peut s'allier à
droite ou à gauche selon ce qu'il pense
être bon et puis une droite vraiment
conservatrice classique libérale ouverte
axée sur les valeurs avec des idées très
claires et très sains alors
qu'aujourd'hui on ne sait vraiment pas
où voter quand on a ces idées là comme
beaucoup de gens à droite est ce que
vous diriez qu'aujourd'hui les
républicains s'est tenue par alain juppé
qui est pas moins centriste à bâle et si
vous voulez enfin la jupe et je dirais
même qu'il est à chaque achat web oui
alain juppé il le dit il le dit
pratiquement il est très mac ronis
tempête
alors vous me direz macron utile à
gauche bon ça c'est un autre débat mais
objectivement les ya un grand écart
entre la tête des républicains
globalement les ce qui dirige le parti
sont globalement centre centre gauche
honnêtement quand on fait leur analyse
très précise alors que les électeurs des
républicains globalement sont plutôt
centre droit donc un écart si vous
voulez entre ce que pensent vraiment les
électeurs des républicains est ce que
défendent les dirigeants des
républicains en tant que tel et on voit
d'ailleurs en ce moment c'est un
tohu-bohu épouvantable vous avez je
tracte élire sur le marché de versailles
j'ai eu une grande masse de républicains
qui sont venus me voir ils sont
complètement désemparés
complètement donc voila moi j'essaie de
dieu aura coûté arrêtons d désemparés et
créer une troisième force
j'allais dire claire précise simple et
puis viennent viennent vers nous ceux
qui ont envie de venir vers nous à
personne ne sera obligé d'aller vers
albert je vous remercie d'être
sur notre plateau laissez moi avec nous
et on passe un tout autre sujet avec une
personne qui a créé avec un ami
rencontré sur les bancs de l'école
une web-série c'est un gant pour toi il
s'appelle jérôme varin ses chroniques
s'appelle les chroniques aéro bonsoir
soir alors déjà avant toute chose pour
nos téléspectateurs
voici un extrait c'est un épisode où
vous apprenez aux gens à retrouver leurs
valises si les ont perdus bien ça donne
des astuces
extraits donc lorsque l'une de ces
mauvaises aventures vous arrivez bien
déjà la première chose à faire c'est
d'aller au comptoir de la compagnie
aérienne qui est normalement équipée
d'un système qui se nomme moreau et qui
permet la traçabilité des bagages dans
le monde entier mais également de
répertorier l'ensemble des bagages
perdus alors on apprend à retrouver ses
bagages
il ya même une chronique ce roland
garros exactement pourquoi vous avez mis
ça en place
alors qu'en fait tout ça c'est parti
d'une réelle frustration quand on était
au tout début de notre formation pilote
recherché des informations sur youtube
sur internet et on ne trouvait rien pas
grand chose c'était il ya deux trois ans
et à cette époque commencé à fleurir des
des chaînes de vulgarisation
scientifique je pense notamment à darty
biology et y penser on était les
premiers à développer des chaînes de
vulgarisation scientifique
il n'y avait rien sur la toile et
n'apparaît sur youtube sur
l'aéronautique concédé avec mon ami et
passionnés tous les deux d'aéronautique
ainsi pourquoi pas faire notre propre
chaîne et ainsi attirer quelque sorte
des gens qui de base ne serait pas
intéressé par érotique mais le serait
parce qu'on parle de ce domaine de
manière simple ça va vraiment beaucoup
plus loin c'est pas juste pour les
personnes non mais c'est pas juste les
pilotes se nouent les verra lierse et
ouvrira tout le monde est ce que je peux
dire l'aviation pour les nuls ou c'est
trop vulgariser non c'est exactement ça
n'est pas pour les nuls dans le sens où
ils sont nuls à moi je dis je sais pas
comment retrouver ma valise si lloris et
ça mais c'est au sens où les gens sont
pas forcément courant et ce ne sont pas
intéressés par ce domaine parce que de
bas ça paraît compliqué mais parce qu'on
peut le gars est suffisamment ça devient
simple et alors il commence à
s'intéresser à l'aviation à l'érotisme
et tout ça de manière générale
quelles sont des thèmes que vous pouvez
aborder c'est vraiment pour le tout
public ou des fois ça un peu plus s'ils
venaient ont pu pousser justement on a
commencé par d un choix d'épisodes tout
public donc les bagages vous en parlais
tout à l'heure on a parlé aussi d'être h
alors c'est un peu anxiogène mais le
mieux c'est d'en parler alors on sait
pour faire cette chronique sur les
crashs
on ne s'est pas appuyé sur un crachat
réel mais sur une expérience qui a été
réalisée aux etats-unis sur un boeing
727 havrais avions qui étaient
téléguidés avec des mannequins terrain
et des caméras ils ont sorti des
observations vaughan ont les traits sur
la table pardon c'est pour ça que ça
vous fait trembler et la troisième était
sur les animaux en vol donc les gens se
posent toujours la question est ce que
si j'emmène mon animal en vol est-ce
qu'il va mourir ou est-ce qu'il va
glacer est ce qu'il va pouvoir respirer
donc on donne toutes ses réponses dedans
et bien évidemment il ne va pas décédée
donc sur les crashs par exemple vous
disais que c'était un peu anxiogène mais
les retours étaient plutôt positives
parce qu'on apprend qu'il ya pas tant de
crash que ça quand on en était lors de
la réimpression c'est tous les mois mais
artistiquement il ya moins de risque en
avions d'abord des problèmes mais quand
les hôtesses et les stewards qui vous
donnent des indications de position ça
sert vraiment à quelque chose
est-ce que vous avez regardé le
chronique j'ai vu le début c'était pas
mon épisode préféré parce que ça me
faisait pas la fin on explique que si
vous n'avez pas la bonne position de
sécurité alors vous pouvez faire ce
qu'on appelle l'effet sous marins donc
vous allez tout droit ou pas dans la
bonne position de sécurité et vous allez
passer sous le siège alors que si vous
étiez en bonne position dans ce cas là
vous allez pouvoir
si bien sûr c'est pas un gros crash
rester en vie et quels sont les retours
par rapport à vos chroniques j'ai pu
voir des commentaires en bas et
les gens sont vraiment contents il ya
même des professionnels on a déjà
répondre c'est tout nouveau
mais effectivement pour l'instant les
retours sont les agréments surpris
d'ailleurs et les retours sont plutôt
positifs d'accord gens comprennent c'est
tout ce qu'on voulait c'était parler
d'un du domaine de l'aéronautique et que
les gens comprennent et des gens qui
sont de base pour intéressés par ce
domaine et les retours qu'on est des
professionnels comme des gens qui ne
connaissent pas forcément sont plutôt
corrects et donc vous êtes partis sur
une saison combien d'épisodes dit mon
objectif c'est de sortir deux vidéos par
mois
donc là on a lancé trois premiers
épisodes et vous avez vu qu'il ya un
quatrième épisode qui sortit sur la
chronique héros qui lance une nouvelle
série donc toujours sur la même chaîne
youtube qu'on a appelée aéro story et
qui se donnera vraiment une nouvelle
série de vidéos dédiées à l'histoire de
l'aéronautique
donc on parlait de roland garros
justement par rapport à l'événement
roland garros les gens ne savent pas
forcément mais c'était un aviateur avant
d'être un terrain tennis voilà et donc
on a décidé d'en parler justement par
rapport à cet événement est là pour
finir alors c'est quoi la suite c'est
quoi les prochains épisodes
alors la suite on va poursuivre
justement la série d elle c est vraiment
la chronique des propres un épisode dont
parlait tout à l'heure on va continuer
la nouvelle série est certainement faire
une nouvelle série à la rentrée tout en
continuant de première sur les voyages
voilà mon collègue parents à madagascar
moi je pars en inde et on va faire une
série sur les voyages c'est de parler de
l'aéronautique au travers de ça et voilà
c'est vraiment en fait on fait ce qu'ils
ont fait de ce qui nous plaît on
n'essaye pas de chercher à parler
d'épisodes en fonction des news ou quoi
que ce soit on essayait de temps en
temps c'était le cas pour roland garros
mais surtout on fait ce qu'on aime donc
ça pourrait vous intéresser tout à fait
avec beaucoup d'attention jeu ce jeu
finira peut-être pilotes ba qui s'ajoute
est le but
et bien je vous remercie à tous les deux
d'être venu sur le plateau c'est la fin
de ce set 8 des invités bonne soirée à
tous
[Musique]